good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy Wednesday oh my God you're
lying slly but surely folks slowly but
surely it's wedness day hump day and
extremely important dare I say integral
part of our ethos here at toast HQ if
you believe you will receive the hump oh
my God wait you just reminded me of the
craziest thing I saw yesterday it better
be crazy you cuz you said believe
receive which always reminds me of ask
believe receive which always reminds me
of Kim Zak Beerman okay and you know the
financials and the you know business
businesses of the ziac Beerman family
are of extreme interest to me and you
know they have all these different
companies one of them being Kashmir
collections with a K and it's like their
skin care company and they put out a
statement yesterday that they like sold
the company slay to 310 Nutrition which
is like another like fake Instagram
brand that like Kim it's like Express
smile Atlanta like Jackie the tangled
web that the ziac Beerman finances weave
never ceases to amaze me I just I love
to see women in business merging and
acquiring merging acquiring making deals
or obus skating responsibility reality
yeah or you know being on the phone with
their attorneys juggling seven business
deals which is so us these days we're
soot we're in such high demand
especially with the
attorneys classic us okay so much to
talk about today yes the first is that
in no particular order of importance my
book club meets tonight and I'm hosting
which means it's the first time I'm
having people in my new apartment what
did you read did you hear about Kitty
Carr right right right right and let me
tell you I didn't really start reading
it I was so like like in a reading Funk
this month and then I got sick and I was
certainly not reading I didn't really
start reading it till yesterday and I'm
so rushed and I'm so annoyed because
it's
amazing oh really it's so interesting
cuz whenever I read books that are like
historical fiction and they go back and
forth there's like a modern element and
then they go back to like the war or
whatever I like can't get away from the
chapters in history far like I'm like
get so funny I can't get away from the
modern chapters I'm like shut up loser
so in this particular book I would say
like 90% of the book is the old stuff
it's amazing so actually don't say
anything more I'm going to read it I
just need no I just want to say like the
fut the modern chapters might be one of
the worst books I've ever read like got
it I needed a strong endorsement to take
it off my want to read list to my
reading list but now I'm going to so
leave it at that say no more L turo say
no more so I've just been like I I'm
like I wish I could be enjoying it more
but because I'm so rushed it's like kind
of ruining it for me which is annoying
that's on me that's on me you know what
that
is
classic lowkey it is
like um so that's just what's been going
on with me and after today I have to
like run home finish the book and start
you know prepping my home because I have
company for the first time which is also
just like a big deal you know yeah so
that's the first thing I wanted to talk
about the second thing I wanted to talk
about is kind of a major update from a
developing story actually it was kind of
a stagnant story because we were talking
about stuff and no one was getting back
to us the trail went cold we a few weeks
ago just kind of put our necks out on
the line like two big back [__] out
there we put ourselves out there because
we heard that like a lot of the men in
podcasting and the men in comedy were
putting together a 5k for like their
health and I want to assume for charity
but even though no one's like said
there's a charity involved like I just
feel like people don't run 5Ks like if
it's not for charity you know yeah yeah
um and we heard they were like all
getting together and like calling each
other up like and they were like trying
to get fellow Comedians and podcasters
involved to raise awareness and and like
nobody reached out to us which just
Baseline was like kind of rude cuz we
are like women of Pride I feel like it's
because we're kind of inaccessible you
know and we're hard to approach oh you
think we're not approachable to I think
we're not approachable to the Bears yeah
I think the Bears are scared they're
Running Scared oh cuz you know what
we're giving we're giving like Mama Bear
energy
two mama bears one cave one cave so we
put ourselves out there we said listen
you know not that you asked her anything
but like you need some women and we'd
love to be
involved Dead Silence dead radio Silence
from the men in comedy they wanted
nothing to do with us we're like okay we
could take the hint but you're really
making this a gender issue when I didn't
find it to be
gendered oh yeah I guess cuz like
Michelle wolf was involved like she's a
woman no but even if there were no women
I would have maybe said that was more of
a coincidence like I just feel like
they're all friends yeah they are we're
like not a part of like the inner circle
of comedy and that's not because we're
women it's cuz we're us yeah we're like
so unfriendly and unapproachable and
like we don't try at all or like follow
anyone on Instagram you know what that's
and we're not we don't run in those
circles like we don't perform at the
comedy Celler we don't live in Austin
like we don't live in Austin that's what
it is I don't think it's gendered
unfortunately Jackie for our career
should we move to Austin like you know
I'm down yeah for our career
but then would we just be like another
comic so true we like such a big pond
for too fish such as us so all that to
say is Bert Cher finally heard our cries
are desperate pathetic cries and he has
responded being like he claims he hadn't
heard of it till yesterday sure B we
like the number two podcast under smart
list but sure he seems authentic he
seems like an authentic creator
no and bird is a lot of things like and
I and I don't know him I've never met
him but I I don't think I would call him
a liar I wouldn't call him
inauthentic oh I
would and he reached out to us on
Instagram saying like I just now hearing
this they would love to have us like
they're kind of like now they're they're
kind of desperate like for us to be
involved oh how the tables have turned
um and they want us there they won't
tell us where it is but it's in May
apparently like the local is very
secretive on M understanding that maybe
I need to listen to their podcast
episode more okay I'm sure if we listen
to their podcast it would clear things
up but the vibe I'm getting just based
on Vibes is that they don't have a
location yet uh and that's like so
Jackson Claude like coded totally we
should do the 5K on the icon of the
Seas I mean it's so big we would have to
walk it like half of it yeah just a lap
love that so I guess like we talked such
a big [__] game and now here we are
like committed to a 5k which I've
personally never done well a fun fact
about me is that I married into a Turkey
Trot family yikes and when Zach and I
were dating and we were in Dallas for
Thanksgiving we did a 5k Turkey Trot so
I have done a 5k that is so crazy to me
so when I see those memes I always show
it to him there's like this running joke
of like people who marry into families
that Turkey Trot families Turkey Trot on
Thursday morning and you usually go out
Wednesday night when you're a young
thing I was so hung over it was the
longest day it was really difficult time
so I'm hoping that this 5K like brings
better 5K memories know I did complete
it and you would have never known but I
just what was your time oh I don't know
so I just need to fully figure out how
many miles are in a 5k 3.1 okay that's
like not really like the worst thing in
the planet I think it would take us
about 30 35 minutes if we run and walk
are we running
combo yeah I'm gon get we walk till we
get bored then me run again the the
thing I do love and this is not a slight
at all it's actually one of my favorite
Parts about like that sort of Austin
comedy podcaster scene is everyone's
overweight and out of shape in that
shape it's just like kind of like a
bunch of like big dudes and I feel like
you know I'm kind of coming in even
though I'm like one of the most out of
shap people on the planet I'm really
working on it I do think I'm coming in
with like an upper hand in that sense
yeah but I feel like they also they were
out of shape becoming in shape people
and that was actually the motivation for
their 5K [__] you're right we're like
kind of all in the same boat no you all
like are just yeah you're all in the
same boat me too we're all just like
we're all just like coming off of O mic
you know we're all coming off of O mic
coming off of pregnancies and we're
getting in shape and we're doing it
together what is that thing
um what was that thing called do you
know what I'm talking about if you would
describe it maybe I'm going to give you
nothing and I just want to know if you
know what I'm talking about like that
weight loss
competition the big loser no loser no no
no it was like not a TV show it was like
just like a thing like people do at
their office yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and like it was all based on like body
percentage what theu whoever like lost
the most weight won a couple Grand yeah
yeah yeah yeah there was like a big pot
I feel like it was The Biggest Loser no
like it was like this game I feel like
our teachers did it at school yeah they
did what the hell was that little like
thing called it was like a trend people
used to do it was like kind of like No
Shave November yeah yeah yeah like
please help weight loss
September yeah what the hell was it some
of them will sound off in the comments
well um I feel like they all did that
another thing they didn't include us in
yeah well they knew that we were already
snatched to the gods they knew like
there was no hope for me like you can't
even make jokes like that anymore why
for a really long time like there was no
hope for me no I know if you from 2
years ago
watch the real that you posted last
night let's talk about it it would have
been a fast five story about this
influencer who posted this reel no lie
no lie no cap no shade calling a lid
yeah putting a lid on it essentially is
what you're saying
lided I want to talk about my viral
moment last night oh did you go viral
yeah I did congratulations thank you so
much and I swear that's not why I did it
I really was sharing like what I thought
was like a good meal and I knew people
would be like oh this is weird but then
I I didn't think it was like going to be
the craziest thing like peanut butter on
a pickle like was it the craziest thing
Jackie people are acting like I put
peanut butter on a pickle like for real
where is this happening because I read
Instagram comment the the most popular
Instagram comments were people being
like I don't want this but I don't hate
it oh no people on Tik Tok are like jail
tury I've been defending you since the
breath I can't do this she can't this is
their last draw like people are like
this like really like broke some people
for me basically I shared on Tik Tok
last night like a meal that I was having
as you guys know I am on my health grind
and I'm really like it's very hard for
me because I'm so picky that it really
does make it difficult for me to like
make good choices and I think a lot of
like how I ended up so unhealthy was
just like a lack of options so I'm
really trying to broaden my horizons and
I felt really excited that like I had
something that was sharable like and I
thought I actually thought like the keto
girls would love it the keto girls like
not in the slightest I just feel like
after years of you not having theirs
they didn't come to your defense no I
this is my bed I will take a nap in it
you kind of alienated yourself from
everyone not me you always have me and
the icon of the
Seas and what more do you need literally
well I need my dinner from last night it
was so good so everyone knows I love
taco meat it's like my favorite thing on
the planet to eat and I usually
obviously eat it with like rice
something like a million Tostitos but
I'm trying to you know pair down so I'm
like what can I eat this taco meat with
that's like not like just nothing and I
put um some eggs in boiled water you
know boiled some eggs it was one of the
hardest things I've ever done ol love
you had to walk me through the whole
thing on Face Time crushed it by the way
made some hard-boiled eggs you inspired
me to make some last night too and mine
came out perfect thanks for asking I
scooped out the yellow oh my God
everyone was also coming at me for
calling them yellow what are they called
yoke sorry I call them the yellows I
don't like the middle like I just like
the boat the The Vessel the icon of the
Seas I just like the icon of the Seas
and I filled it up with taco meat and it
made like my my own little aido taco you
know I'm not keto by the way I don't
know why I keep saying that um they came
for my
neck well here's what like to me it's
not that radical but I guess something
about us is one we love in our family to
eat egg whites as like vessels for
anything I we sometimes have Laughing
Cow Cheese I like don't put me in that
boat I don't do that [__] no but it's a
great vessel it is and we've always seen
it as a vessel maybe not everyone sees
it as a vessel oh and by the way let me
tell you why it's the perfect vessel and
people were shocked that I eat
hardboiled eggs but the thing about
hardboiled eggs is they taste like
nothing yeah so like I don't know why it
was shocking people that I eat that like
yes me eating cottage cheese that's
shocking I agree with you but me eating
a hard-boiled egg it's like me literally
eating like a salty and like it tastes
like nothing yeah it tastes and it's
packed with protein no and it was so
good I have so like do you know how
excited I am to go home I have leftovers
like that's what I'm having for lunch
that is exciting but I got roasted and
the thing is everyone was yucking my
yums and after years of doing it to
other people like I truly deserve
nothing but that no nothing but that and
back to my original point of if old you
could see you now she would hate you but
I guess that's that's called growth wait
I do want to say I do think it's going
to take us like way more time than 30
minutes to run a 5k because like just
based on my like treadmill Vibes I do
run walk run walk like and by the time
I'm done with like a 30 40 minute thing
I've literally went like a mile and a
half so I think it's literally going to
take me like 2 hours no well when you're
going to train and we'll get it to like
I think 45 minutes is a good goal then
am I kind of dreading this no CL it's
going to be fun it'll be great for our
careers you know by the like the only
thing carrying me through the motivation
here for me is like The Thirst the
attention the followers hoping maybe
we'll you know be able to sit down with
Tom and Bert and record like a a toast X
bear collab podcast you know like
rubbing elbows with some of the greates
and I just want to say like if we do
like two toasters one cave episode like
we will be bringing couples together
like the couples are are literally like
hetero couples are the man who listens
to two bears and the wife who listens to
a toaster like and if they could like we
would be bringing families together like
like it' be good Christian values you
know totally date night yeah Sweet Life
on Deck of icon of the Seas and honestly
I think they have a patreon too like we
should monetize that [__] like we could
retire yeah they do big Tings on patreon
so it's worth it and I'll do it and I
will start training so feel free to send
me I know there's like apps and stuff
like it's actually apparently like quite
easy to train for a 5k like allegedly um
if you're not me but send them our way
because we like we're getting started
maybe we'll start when we're together
great oh yeah let's see let's see how
long it takes us on the treadmill to do
three and three Mones how long can you
run like how many like
minutes the I mean it's hard to say like
right now but in my like once I'm just
like at an reg average myself
at least a whole like maybe two songs
straight wow two songs that's a lot and
depends what speed I'm going and yeah
and it's like when we say running are we
jogging or we like
sprinting both fall under but no we're
at jogging nobody Sprints in a marathon
or a
5k yeah well this is just all very
exciting slow and steady wins the race
right the tortoise in the hair it's just
crazy like some people run a marathon
like 3 hours like I could technically do
the 5K in like 2 hours we're all running
our own race tury literally comparison
is the thief of Joy that's beautiful
thank you so what's do with you we've
got a great show by the way today's
Wednesday in in keep sorry in keeping
with our scheduling update from last
week dear toasters has been moved to
tomorrow Jackie and I both watched
Vander pump ruls so what's do with you
Jax thank you for asking again um very
exciting developments here I'm making
baby food this morning we are in the
baby food stage of life which is just so
exciting nothing sweeter than some
homemade baby food from a homesteading
tradwife I made some homemade applesauce
this morning to start my day and that is
our first foray which is very exciting
and
sweet just you know they grow up so fast
they really really do and I I enjoy
making baby food I I I feel like people
with like subsequent kids like they're
just like have the Gerber jar you know
it's like the first kid gets you know
the best and the fourth kid's eating off
the floor the first kid like I'm picking
my own apples yeah right you're growing
them in your bushel yeah but I'm no I'm
doing it again I I really I enjoy it I
find it soothing and it gives me peace
of mind especially as I finish weaning I
I don't feel like I'm no longer making
Chinese food because we're now we're
just moving to a different medium so
it's for nice I can't wait to try some
of your homesteading fresh baby food
when I come see you this weekend which
I'm literally so excited any request I
actually feel like you would like my
baby food cuz it's totally clean and
you're you're an almond mom now no not
only that like when I see Harry's plate
I'm like [__] me up like that I there's
nothing on Harry's plate I wouldn't eat
it's just good old-fashioned tury's
Choice like it's always like a breaded
chicken not
breaded sometimes it's breaded sometimes
it's breaded it depends like breaded
except one thing about Harry that's so
weird he doesn't like pasta he doesn't
like pasta he doesn't like potatoes
and there's one other may maybe har and
I are kind of like growing apart har the
thing is he he didn't like them so I
like stopped offering them right I'm
sure if I kept offering it he would
eventually eat it but like why if you
don't want to eat it don't eat it no it
sounds like me and Harry are kind of
like growing apart that's growth man
like I said they grow so fast so yeah if
you need me to make you any baby food
let me know I'm just so excited to spend
the weekend with you we're going to have
the best time oh and I am vlogging today
for book club oh fun so people will see
like I'm not going to do a home tour
ever cuz we already went into like why I
think we've evolved as a brand but as a
society as a society I do think um
you'll get some nice sneak peeks in my
apartment and all my new furniture and
my H bits and pieces I like that and we
make us we'll all feel like we're there
yeah and I'm really excited about that
and it's just another great day of you
know being alive and having our health
100% Yesterday I did something so
exciting which was I did 2hour driving
Lon
how many people did you kill
zero zero very exciting we like I was
literally just in the parking lot we
were like going about my normal day and
I was like showing him my areas of
struggle and smart yeah we drove to the
mall because i' did you go back to the
scene of the crime no no I was just like
I kept telling him like I kept alluding
to like right on red tra you didn't you
didn't cite the actual incident no I
kept wanting to but he wasn't really
interested I think I think he was just
trying to tell me to let it go yeah
which is probably the best thing for you
in this moment yeah but I really got my
parking down what I didn't realize it's
so much easier to park turning left into
a spot versus turning right because you
could see so much better it's on your
side and as you also you also need to
like to see the other side no but like
it's just are you talking about parallel
park or like pulling into a park spot
pulling into a spot it's just naturally
easier to pull into a spot that's on
your left I didn't realize this but I
was doing that's funny I feel the
opposite really why do you feel as such
I don't know I feel like if I'm in a
parking lot and there's a space on both
sides of me I'm just more inclined to do
like a wide right turn I don't know why
CU you like a
challenge no because pick the hard one
cuz I'm not afraid of a
challenge Loki I'm so glad you brought
that
up one of the weirdest and worst lines
in cinematic history is that moment in
legally blind but like it's a sleigh no
it's but the thing is it's not it's a
it's a
cringe but it's l like nothing she does
is actually cringe no no no but that's
like the one thing she does that's the
thing L Woods is this woman who's just
like she's Unstoppable anything she does
is cool she's so self- assured she's so
capable she's so everything and it's the
not only the line itself but it's also
the delivery of that line the whole
moment in that lecture where she like
changed cuz I'm not afraid of a
challenge like
I guess maybe the writers weren't
feeling well that day but it works and I
like to cite it I'm glad you brought it
up because I've been meaning to talk
about it for a minute okay well another
thing I've been meaning to talk about so
I learned that when in doubt I can park
on the left side you know if I'm feeling
not confident but I was trying to
practice all the hard ones I worked on
my right turn into the parking spot wide
turn crushed it crushed oh my God then
momy came home he had me back into my
driveway like the way that my car is
parked right now it's like literally I
could never do that again yeah yeah yeah
no you need a professionals help yeah
but no lessons were learned and I'm
really glad that I did I'm feeling more
comfortable and I'm going to really try
and get out there and every day the
drive the teacher like thought he was I
think he was a little confused why I was
doing this like I'm a perfectly fine
driver but it's more so it's the mental
it's a mental anguish the thing is the
mental anguish like won't go away until
you just practice practice experience
experience right so I'm glad I did it
okay
goodh I'm glad that you're here well
thank you did you watch fanom prump
rolls yeah I didn't I didn't I didn't
enjoy myself neither did I I watched it
this morning it took me maybe two hours
to get through the episode I just kept
pausing it to do anything else no I
completely agree we'll talk about it in
the TV recap so that is postponing dear
toasters till tomorrow so the DT the DT
stands and there are
many we'll have to wait also I'm sure
it's not a story but you know Taylor did
her Tokyo show saw this is like such a
strange time difference because like I
woke up and the show like had just ended
you know ye yeah and we like I got the
surprise songs first thing in the
morning okay and so the first surprise
song she's saying was dear reader love
which is a very symbolic because it's
the final song on midnight so it's kind
of like the closing of this most recent
chapter of midnights because now we're
about to enter the Dead Poet Society for
sure but I do feel like it's actually
like not great symbolism because it's
like the first show of a new chapter
and we don't the like she's doing
another show tonight but you just played
the last
song no it's symbolic and I like it and
also she's never played it before and
that's literally my favorite song time I
feel like it was kind of like babus to
book club coded and she knew you were
hosting tonight and just wanted to give
you a bit of encouragement dear reader I
mean I would love that yeah maybe Taylor
knew my book club was meeting honestly
that makes more sense to me I mean I
could see it
like we all know like Taylor's number
one Confidant In This Moment is Kelly
teller Kell Kelly Taylor loves the toast
she probably knows my book loves meting
like I wouldn't be surprised if
seriously she told Taylor that my book
love it just like came up and that
inspired her to sing to your reader it's
such an insanely delicious song I love
that song and then she also sang Holy
Ground which is like one of her
favorites like she's always singing it
okay those are two of my like those
would be on my top oh
wow top 15 choices I'll find I'll find
videos and send it to you thank you
reals preferred reals preferred of
course let's get into the stories I
think so too we've Dilly DED long oh my
God we really have it's it's late okay
without further Ado here are the fast
life stories that you need to know and
the fastf stories that you need to know
are brought to you by poppy it's no
secret that soda has become a dirty word
too sugary too syrupy we don't blame you
for wanting to leave it in the past but
that era of soda is officially over so
you know I'm a Diet Coke fiend and while
I have not sworn it off completely and I
don't think I will ever get there it's
an important part of my day I have
paired down immensely how much soda I
drink there's so many other healthier
Alternatives they taste as good and they
don't have a lot of the BS in it so I
wanted to try it for myself I had heard
poppy for Years everybody on Tik Tok is
obsessed with poppy and really like I
understand why they are that [__] you
know like they really are kind of doing
the most over at poppy so it is a better
for you soda made with clean ingredients
it has 5 grams of sugar or less and it
has prebiotics there are literal
prebiotics in each can it's you can feel
good about what's in your can with the
classic flavors like Cola which
obviously is going to resemble a Diet
Coke doc pop root beer you could say
good empty calories artificial
ingredients and high fructose corn syrup
so the doc pop flavor tastes just like
Dr Pepper so if you're trying to like
replace a habit like for me it's Diet
Coke I know some people love Dr Pepper
they have flavors that are so similar
that make it really easy to transition I
I'm not going to lie like I have not
stopped drinking soda um but I drink a
lot less you could shop poppy on Amazon
for 15% off with code toast5 off it's
also available in retailers Nationwide
they also have fresh fruit flavors so
besides for the soda they also just make
like Delicious Fruit beverages like
strawberry Cherry Lemon Cherry Limeade
orange grape they're bursting with the
juiciest flavor so shop poy on Amazon
for 15% off with code toast 15 off and
of course in retailers Nationwide that's
toast5 off today's episode is brought to
you by stamps.com after the hype of the
new year we all start to settle into our
routines but for businesses who do a lot
of mailing and shipping we've got to
keep it moving stamps.com streamlines
all your mailing and shipping to
turbocharge your operational
efficiencies Jackie remember I called
you yesterday and I couldn't remember
what I had to say yeah I remember remind
me in three minutes
stamps.com is streamlining all your
mailing and shipping to turbocharge your
operational efficiencies and the
stamps.com app is like a post office in
your pocket so you can stay on top of
things even if you're on the go so the
post office elevated is basically what
stamps.com is with with postage rates
increasing all the time and they just
increased again stamps.com has the best
discounts in the industry with rates you
can't find anywhere else like up to 89%
off USPS and UPS stamps.com will
automatically tell you your cheapest and
fastest shipping options so you don't
have to navigate all the different
carriers it's a One-Stop shop for your
mailing and shipping needs and for 25
years they have been an indispensable
resource for over a million businesses
whether they're mailing out checks
invoices legal documents books or
anything else use stamps.com to print
postage wherever you do do your business
it is a stressfree solution for every
small business all you need is a
computer and a printer and if you have a
business you probably already have both
of those things they even will send you
a free scale so you'll have everything
you need to get started if you need a
package pickup you can easily schedule
it through your stamps.com dashboard so
keep your mailing and shipping moving at
the speed of your business with
stamps.com sign up with promo code toast
for a special offer that includes a
4-week trial plus free postage and a
free digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts required just
go to stamps.com Click the microphone at
the top of the page and enter code toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by signos so the CDC estimates that
there are approximately 96 million
American adults more than one in three
that have pre-diabetes of those with
pre-diabetes more than 80% don't know
that they have it so a healthy weight is
going to allow your insulin to to work
more efficiently and can help you keep
your blood sugars within a normal range
a healthy diet and regular exercise are
the best way to help bring your blood
sugar levels back to a healthy range and
signos can help you shortcircuit this
cycle by using data directly from your
body to design a weight loss plan that's
unique to your lifestyle signos is the
only company that combines a continuous
glucose monitor with an aid driven app
to deliver real-time glucose monitoring
for Optimal Health and weight management
so with signos you can literally see
which foods are causing your blood sugar
to spike above reasonable levels and get
time alerts to do a bit of exercise to
bring them back down so on average
people make about 227 food choices a day
and just being better informed having
more information about your body this
data directly from your body is super
super helpful so you can learn the
difference between stress eating and
physical hunger you can manage your
energy throughout the day you can sleep
better at night there's so many
different ways you'll see so many
different results after using signos and
the lifestyle changes that you'll just
really start implementing without even
noticing signos removes the guesswork of
weight loss and provides you with the
tools tools and knowledge that you need
to develop healthier habits it combines
your data from the CGM the continuous
glucose monitor with an aid driven app
to deliver realtime glucose insights for
Optimal Health and weight management
right now signos has an exclusive offer
just for our listeners go to signos SI
no.com and get 20% off select Plans by
using Code toast today that's sos.com
code toast to get 20% off select plans
today thank you la well um our first
story is actually wait I remember what I
wanted to tell you I called Jackie
yesterday and I had to yell at her about
something and then I couldn't remember
what it was oh and I just remembered
would you hold up your iPad for the
class oh you want to shame me Jackie
we're running a business here and we had
these absolutely gorgeous custom iPad
cases made with our logos so we could I
don't know have branding not only did
you take yours off which seems beyond
unnecessary you didn't put it back on
and now we're giving Apple logo like
they need more like like he needs more
money like Jackie I'm sorry leria I took
it off for my son so that he could enjoy
my iPad when he needed to and that he
wouldn't disturb the beautiful case that
you made me that I wanted to protect so
I took it off and put on a kid-friendly
case for
him you can take it up with him I will
actually first the rice and now the iPad
case seems like me Harry and I have a
lot to discuss when I get down there
yeah I don't know like we have you know
not enough time and so much to discuss
that maybe we I don't know we he should
like sleep in my bed or something like
just to save time he's welcome too yeah
just like put it back on you know this
is a place of business I'll think about
it Jacky Jacky it's right over there
Jacky this is Jacky this is a place of
business not a daycare no I think it's
both actually I think it is too and
maybe I don't know maybe you should put
it back on like now J are by the way I
don't know if you know like our Clips
have gone so viral this last week I mean
we've been like our best Tik Tok yes
like multiple videos with hundreds of
thousands like and you're just out here
slinging Apple logos like go get your
case um you know what actually the
Universal Music non-cooperation with Tik
Tok is good for us because we don't use
music and they need like fresh audio
sounds and that's what we provide oh my
God you're so right now that's
capitalizing on the moment as we should
as we will and you haven't gotten up to
go get your iPad case no I haven't
because I don't feel like it I don't I'm
like it HR will be hearing about this I
think that they should and you'll be
getting a call from Olivia asre I think
that you will be getting a call too are
you ready for our first story yes it's
some book news AA Garten quietly
releases quietly announces a 2024 Memoir
release date so AA just celebrated her
76th birthday and eagley fans noticed
that in the bio of her Instagram it says
mem coming out October 1st
2024 let me tell you something about AA
she's a little weird
like I feel like there's all this like
Fanfare for her in the culture she's
like such an integral part of really
like Millennial life and she like kind
of hates it I feel why do you feel she
hates it and why does this make you feel
that way I don't know I just feel like
there's something weird about AA like I
really mean that okay do you remember
that
account help me um
um that was like an AA fan page like and
they just like put AA in pop culture
moments and it like a couple of years
ago it was like the biggest Instagram
account what the hell was that page
called not the biggest Instagram account
follow it let me see it was called like
I elicious no what was it called
like I
know I feel like for a while like all we
were talking about was that Instagram
account I don't know I don't I can't
find and like there are so many like
professional AA impersonators on social
media I'm always see I mean like and
everybody dresses up as her like I feel
like there's so much fanfare for her and
like she never sort of like engages with
it or like even like likes anything on
Instagram I feel like and I remember
with that Instagram account that blew up
about AA she blocked them like she
didn't like it okay but I also think
she's 76 years old and she's not like
desperate for the Instagram Fanfare she
just wants to make her meals and enjoy
her life and that's okay with me I don't
get the vibe that she like hates it but
but she doesn't like do the most and
like you
know get in there and because she's not
thirsty she doesn't need it yeah no no
and this is like a really not thirsty
way to announce your Memoirs yeah but I
think that's exactly what we need she's
the exact sort of person who should be
writing her memoirs I actually think her
story is really interesting me and she
must have a lot to say she's probably
learned so much along the way like yes
please I will read your Memoirs thank
you yeah I feel like a lot of people
don't realize like she was like a she
had like a catering company and then it
got like really popular in like fancy
circles in the Hamptons and like how you
catapult that to like really what she
did is super impressive I would be like
it's definitely giving like Bob Iger
energy no and she used to live in DC she
was like worked in
politics Jeffrey yeah congresswoman AA
yeah and she only fell into like being a
chef like this a professional chef like
just out of hobby yeah that's
interesting I wonder what you know DCA
was like yeah DCA
so lowkey announcement I mean October
1st is really far away so is there a
title no let's let's the Memoirs of
anina how easy is that but it wasn't
easy probably to get where she
is okay how easy is that
colon to find out not easy at all yeah
yeah yeah so I love a colon in a memoir
it's like my favorite thing I mean you
have to have a CO and I think it's like
in the contracts like it's a subtitle
it's in Chicago MLA except for Memoirs
of AA speaks for itself well that's true
when you have a title as strong as that
like no other sort of punctuation is
required um and my next Memoir is of
course going to be called searching for
victimhood the Claud ashray story not
Memoirs of
aangi maybe my
third you guys have to buy the second
just so I can do that yeah oh my God if
you ever write other Memoirs we're gonna
have so much fun with the title I know
like the first one had to be like you
know brand safe girl with no job you
know I made the bestseller list like I'm
good I don't care about the future when
like I can always say now like I'm a
bestselling author so the next book's
like we're [__] around like yeah
we're going to do something wild totally
I feel like Barefoot dresses could be
something
like walking through life with the
Barefoot
Contessa dancing through life she's not
dancing she's cooking through life what
about this talk tury to me
you like that I guess it would kind of
be more so the title of like my sex tape
yeah yeah than my Memoirs
yeah
yeah okay so for Barefoot Contessa
like Barefoot Confessor oo I love we
like Confessions of a Teenage
Barefoot confessions of
Ana
i i i to say
something
I this is tough yeah it's hard it's hard
you would think it would be easy there's
so much fodder with her right and like I
mean obviously she's also not like silly
goofy so it has to be serious that's
what I'm saying she gives us nothing but
like if it were me it would be like The
Vagina Monologues Thea
monologues that's it and it could be
short
stories short stories you know what chy
chy chy short the Ina monologues colon
short stories from a short woman cuz
she's like four feet you that's rude no
she's not you know what's one of my
favorite jokes do share like how when
you go to get a recipe online they give
you like the longest
synopsis yeah about what the recipe
means to them and their Heritage and
their family and like a million things
jump to recipe ingredients like nobody
read needs it why did they keep doing it
oh I don't know and by the way AA is 5'3
so she is like literally our height and
I find that the jump to recipe button is
harder and harder to find on it like
they keep making it smaller and more
hidden what is harder to find the jump
to recipe button or the unsubscribe
button in the bottom of an email because
they've started to get really creative
where like it used to be underlined
because it's hyperlink yeah so at the
bottom it would be like copyright the
address and then there would be like one
blue hyperlink and you would know that
now they don't hyperlink it so you
literally just need to search you need
to pair like a monacle to find the
unsubscribe button at the bottom of
emails yeah I just I need to find a a
chef who doesn't want to share her
story and just wants to share recipes
yeah you need to find like a shy Chef
who's like I do someone to tell me about
growing up on the farm and making this
their favorite spaghetti meatballs for
their little brother you need to find
like a really really private Chef not in
like a private CH sense in like a a chef
who has like a big sense of privacy yeah
yeah have you seen the joke that it's
like I want to read a thriller about a
blogging Chef who is admitting to a
crime of murder in every recipe like in
the beginning but nobody ever puts it
together because nobody reads it they're
so long-winded oh and nobody reads it
yeah does everyone just jumps to recipe
so true then if you look back on all the
recipes like all the clues were there I
do also have an issue with recipe
culture in terms of like the SEO of it
all because like when I if I just were
to Google like you know corn muffin like
the first one they would give me like
would be the worst one like factually
yeah it's hard you have to look at the
reviews how many reviews it has some of
them have like thousands and it's five
stars you could trust it that's why it's
also to build up a rapport it's good to
build up a rapport with a what is it
called like a food blogger because you
know if you like their taste like I can
trust if if Half Baked Harvest had a
vegetarian meatball which is what I was
looking for the other day that I would
go with it I'm sorry a vegetarian
meatball how does that make any sense
isn't that just a ball like a veggie
meatball yeah like a almost like a
veggie patty oh okay yeah like a Beyond
ball no not Beyond like made with
veggies as the substitute he like is
that just a salad though like for real
no like it would be like eggplant maybe
zucchini like I was looking for a way to
put it all together to be a meatball I
didn't get very far and what do you have
against meat like in this scenario oh no
I I mean I make meatballs multiple times
a week Jack meatballs oh thanks tury
I'll make you some here I we're always
having meatballs and so I just wanted I
was like curious and I had like two
eggplants and two zucchinis in my fridge
so I was like I wonder if I can make a
meatball with this you make me a
meatball and I'll make you tury's famous
egg tacos oh I would love that how was
your taco meat so good I use ground
turkey oh the best ground turkey and Old
El Paso like beef a ground beef is overp
Party by the way I agree cuz also when
you're cooking ground beef like all that
oil like are you still I can never know
you're supposed to keep the oil in the
pan everyone says like use it but then
everyone's like get it out and honestly
when I take it out it's gross and when I
leave it it's gross like I don't know
what to do turkey doesn't have that
problem like turkey and also I know
you're not going to agree with me but
ground chicken [__] too love ground
chicken I like ground chicken chili I
love ground chicken every like just like
turkey they're to me so similar and I'm
just done with ground beef like I'm so
glad we're putting it out there yeah I
do still like ground beef chili like
that's the only thing I'll really accept
but ground beef just really needs to be
cooked for a really long time
and it needs to be really small yeah
we're just like we're we're such almond
ladies it's just it's too
fatty I'm such an alond lady this
podcast is becoming like an insufferable
diet podcast it's giving like huberman
energy I love that me too and it's just
like so important to constantly be
changing yeah I was just having this
conversation with some we were talking
about like the landscape of podcasting
and all these different shows and like
shows that used to be big and that
aren't anymore what a fun combo it
really was
and I'm like lightening it up like it
was really
mean and we were just like cting this up
like this podcast that used to be really
popular like what went wrong like we
couldn't really figure out what it was
and and we really boiled it down to like
a lack of evolution in terms of content
in terms of format in terms of
everything you have you can't be afraid
of change that's something I've learned
very late in life cuz don't get me wrong
like change is the worst but now that
I've changed so much about my life and
I'm so happy like I'm probably one in
the happiest side from Theo dying in the
war in Israel I'm probably one of the
happiest places I've really ever been
and that's due to that change you know
yeah Claudia I've been trying to tell
you for years sometimes self- care looks
like hard
work no and sometimes I like like
literally yesterday in the tub I like
sat back and I was like in the last year
like I did the two things I never ever
ever thought I could possibly be
physically capable of I lost the weight
and I stopped vaping like two things
that were just like a fabric of my life
like it was just a fact it wasn't
anything I was even trying to change
because I knew I literally it was utile
to even try and then once I did the
weight thing and I totally had help with
the OIC I never would have been able to
do it without I realized like I was
capable of doing big things and that's
what really kind of gave me the courage
to quit the VAP and number three skiing
let me think skiing reading reading
that's like an old one now yeah we're
just used to you reading yeah and it's
like oh we didn't think I could do
something that required me to like lay
down I mean you know like everything
else is really physical
yeah great yeah oh by the way I'm
wearing the sneakers oh can you get me a
pair I was going to say I think you I
think like you could treat me to a
pair by the way I'll make you a deal put
the case on go get your iPad case I'll
will buy you the shoes right now well
you will have them like delivered as and
by the way they I bought them on shop op
through Amazon they came the next day
you have yourself a deal okay what size
are you shop seeven uh seven what size
do you get how do they run um I got a 72
and they look like a little small when I
put them on I was like shook but they
fit completely fine so okay send me the
confirmation that goes on women seven
add to bag and it's going to be so easy
because I have your address in my Amazon
account oh yeah you've been sending some
things yes uh I'm so excited they would
look so cute with my outfit today don't
you
think I do think I think it would look
great with your outfit today thank you
Claudia I wait I have to log in with
Amazon you know why I need them cuz I
need nice looking shoes that I can drive
in oh These are nice looking shoes that
you can driveing they're also like very
old lady very Florida you know what I
mean like I love it okay I'm addressing
it to you oh I'm so excited let me put
in your address you got yourself a is
the iPad case on look at that we love
she can be bought we love love love you
think this could be like a business
expense since we're like putting it on
the show like we're making content with
it right right right delivered by Friday
should I pay the extra should I pay the
extra $3.99 to for you to have them
tomorrow outing on Friday I'll wear them
on Friday if yeah cuz I have somewhere I
need to be and they would look cute for
that I'll tell you what I have to do and
you'll you'll agree it's a perfect shoe
order place they're also linked on my
like to know it if anybody wants done oh
my God thanks tury that's exciting I got
a new pair of shoes pleasure doing
business with you pleasure doing
business is with you
yeah oh I'm so excited what was I aren't
they cool by and for to finish my
thought from earlier these are the shoes
I was talking about on Friday when I saw
Ariel charis's story and I was like
should I get the jacket I didn't get the
jacket but I got the shoes and so far
I'm loving it so maybe it'll inspire me
to get you know complete the look
complete the look yeah
great well are you ready for our next
story is this only number two it's only
number two yeah Charlie demilio and
Landon Barker have broken up after more
than a year of dating so if you guys
have kids this is something that you
could talk to them about um it's
probably a tough time for them but
Landon posted on his Instagram saying
hey everyone I would like to let you
guys know that Charlie and I are no
longer together we broke up to focus on
ourselves we are still friends and have
so much love for each other I am
incredibly grateful for the time we
shared and hope you can respect our
decisions thank you love you all so
much so there was a time when like I
really cared about the kids of Tik Tok
and that time has
passed of course I don't care about them
as Tik Tock kids I care about them as
part of the Kardashian
Barker ecosystem exactly and even though
they're really young I felt like they
were a really solid couple that I didn't
this was shocking but I didn't fores
seee breaking up yeah no they seemed
like oddly stable yeah and given just
the circumstances a serious longterm
relationship even though they're so
young and obviously it's not you know
and I never questioned like whether or
not they were going to stay together
they just kind of like were they were
always together they were always like at
serious family functions together like
that's where you bring your serious
partner so I just like always kind of
assumed she would be in the fold and I
know that they just came out with season
two of the demilio show and like I do
kind of look at the deos ever since I
watched that first season with like an a
hypercritical eye and I like the when I
watch Like Dixie and and I watch their
content like I see them as like such
fragile sort of broken young women and
the show really highlighted how broken
they were and I feel like a men's
sadness for them and like I whenever
like they give me a really big pit I
feel like they hate their life they hate
being famous and I feel like everyone
around them like their parents included
like foed on them like they give me the
biggest pit I don't know if that's the
actual reality but that's really the
vibe I got from that show I was
surprised they like put it out cuz it
was so honest yeah I don't think like
having a mental breakdown every single
day in you're 16 like and your parents
keep putting you to work and there's
like more projects let's start a shoe
company we're started a venture capital
confirm like it gave me such a pit yeah
and when I first saw it I was like I
think this is really emblematic of like
the Mental Health crisis in this country
they're like the perfect example of like
16-year-old girls who are spent all
their time on social media of course
they're literally having mental
breakdowns every single day like won't
leave their room and it's like actually
even though it's they're having a hard
time with it like things are on the
surface good for them you know of course
likes them they're they're not the
villains they're not getting canceled
like it's all good and it's still bad
they can't even enjoy it right because
it's so unnatural they're so young they
started so young so much was foed on
them like so quickly like I don't know I
really um I have a terrible pit when it
comes to those girls I like watching
that first season of that show was like
really it was a tough watch I was
surprised they put it out like the thing
is I it kind of made the parents look
like bad they're too close to it I don't
think they can see it the way an
outsider can and I think they in putting
it out one it's another job and business
and we're have a reality show that's
like every 's goal these days yeah but I
think also it might have been like a a
cry for sympathy like you know we're
people too and but I think that all the
negatives as you stated outweigh
whatever positives like because
definitely when I saw it I'm like if I
ever have anything to say about the de
like I wouldn't say like they can't
handle it like it definitely makes you
want to go just like easy yeah not that
I'm going to go hard on the demilios but
I do feel like they were getting a lot
of hate and now if you've seen that show
like you wouldn't send any there way
they're also just like nice girls and
why would you hate on them no for sure
and also like I think we talked so much
about the Mental Health crisis in this
country like the amount of kids who are
depressed and suicidal like it's at a
higher rate than ever it's not normal
and like this is you know this this is a
role model for so many young women and
it's like look how depressed they are
and they have amazing lives you know and
it's like the majority of kids these
days want to grow up to be an influencer
and here are they want to be Charlie
they are the most successful ones it
doesn't get bigger than this or quicker
you can't be like she's the highest in
her field and so unhappy so like what is
that say for the kids right right no the
whole thing like really gives me a
terrible pit and I feel like it's so
such a small difference like Addison Ray
being like three years older than
Charlie when the whole thing happened I
think like and she and I think Addison R
really struggled especially she went
through like public stuff with her
family like but I think the difference
and maybe it's just that Addison hasn't
shared as much as Charlie has on the on
the show but just the vibe that I get
get is like her being a little bit older
like the tiniest bit tougher like saved
her a little bit yeah but what about
Dixie she's a little bit older and she's
still having so it's also just
like your
makeup yeah but also how that hadison
Taken like several steps back whereas
like Dixie is constantly doing more
right and they're like just always doing
new things like they have a new shoe
company and then Dixie does music and
then Charlie wanted to do music like on
top of being social media Stars they
have a ring light line at Target a
clothing line at Hollister like it's
like never the $25 million vure Capital
firm they started like it's like a lot
yeah yeah yeah well that makes me even
sadder that they broke up because now
she's probably dealing with heartbreak
too right oh and then that was the other
thing from the show I felt like one of
the really only it seemed like the only
bright spot in Dixie's life was her
relationship with Noah Beck who was they
said on the show like so neurotypical
like he didn't have the same like mental
health issues or like anxiety social
media was just like a fun job for him
like he was so like oddly like simple
about the whole thing and I felt like
that he was so good for her and then
they broke up and it's like I feel like
probably Landon was similar like
Landon's very used to this he grew up
like this it's not that big of a deal
for him and he probably stabilized a lot
of the insecurities that Charlie had and
so yeah it is sad yeah and no one dixie
is sad too thereit wasn't ever like you
know one day announced I feel like it
was like people pulling back the layers
so I was in denial yeah and then I
forgot about it but they were really
cute couple
yeah so I hope I hope everyone's okay
wishing everyone the best wishing
everyone the best as always as we always
do for every person except for Annie
Lennox except for Annie Lennox we're
Wisher wellwishers we are wellwishers
are you ready for our next story yeah
Taylor Swift is demanding this college
student stop tracking her private jet so
when it comes to dealing with a Florida
College student who uses public data and
social media to track the private jets
of billionaires politicians and other
celebrities Taylor Swift apparently
can't just shake it off in late December
Taylor's Camp hit Jack Sweeney a junior
studying Information Technology at the
University of Central Florida with a
ceas Andis letter that blamed his
automated tracking of her private jet
for tipping off stalkers as to her
location in the letter attorneys from
the law firm venal accused Sweeney of
effectively providing individuals intent
on harming her or with nefarious or
violent intentions a roadmap to carry
out their plans Sweeney provided that
letter in an email to the AP in that
message he emphasized that while he has
never intended to cause harm he also
strongly believes in the important
importance of transparency and public
information he said one should
reasonably expect that their jet will be
tracked whether or not I'm the one doing
it as it is public information after all
a spokesperson for tailored echoed the
legal complaint saying that the timing
of stalkers suggests a connection to his
flight tracking sites the spokesperson
did not respond to questions seeking
elaboration of that charge such as
whether stalkers have been seen waiting
for Swift at the airport when her plane
arrived or alternatively if there is
evidence that stalkers have somehow
interfered inferred her location from
the arrival time of her fight so by the
way this is the same person who ran Elon
musk's account Jet and Elon Musk had
actually offered him $5,000 to turn the
the account off and he was like you know
50 would be better I don't know what
ended up happening at first he just
pleaded with him like on a human level
being like can you please stop doing
this like I have such crazy stalkers
like I have a I have kids like and the
guy was like No And then he was like
okay what about $5,000 I don't know how
it ended but this is the same person who
it was in elon's book and at first he
was like you know he's a free speech
Warrior so he was like the account must
day and then he just about faing was
like [__] principal you're off and he
kicked him off he banned elon's jet so
Taylor's having the same issue that Elon
was having we yes it is public
information through the FAA website but
I think it requires a lot of leg work to
figure out and this person's just making
it like so easy for people to see yeah
this person is not breaking the law no
and I think it's interesting like Taylor
obviously wants his account taken down
which she's totally entitled to I'm like
her level of stalker is like she has
millions like they're insane they go and
sleep in her bed like they're freaks so
and I I'm sure that there is some sort
of connection between this account and
her stalkers like I'm sure of it I do
think it's interesting that the route
she chose to take was like cease and
assist and kind of like legal strong
arming as opposed to just being like
what if I gave you you know $50,000 to
shut up cuz it's clear that this person
like would take money is it yeah because
when Elon offered him $5,000 he said it
wasn't enough money okay but then you
know and he's and also this is like a
college student like what
$50,000 I think it's the principle of
like you're going to pay someone a lot
of
money I know but for for your safety
like [__] principal yeah I mean Elon
said [__] principal honestly taylored
should be reaching out to Elon and be
like hey can you [__] principal on mine
too yeah no by the way for sure I'm sure
like if this doesn't go her way like
she's on her way to Pal Alto yeah
because he also made her unsearchable on
X when those AI images were circulating
so he can just kind of like do stuff you
might want to be nice to Elon yeah I I
know a lot a lot of people um like think
those accounts are important because
they like highlight you know her carbon
emissions yeah but we know she's like
not an environmental Queen like we know
so the point was made and I saw the
funniest tweet because like two weeks
ago Taylor Swift's one of her like
classic New York New York New York oh my
God New York
stalkers one of her New York stalkers
was arrested like three days in a row
each day he came to like lay in her bed
got arrested and then came back the next
day to do it and the swifties were
freaking out they were like why isn't
this guy in jail and the Tweet was like
oh swifties are about to learn about
bail
reform cuz like in New York like you
like if you get arrested like bar like
they just like let you out like it's
like kind of crazy so it's like how is
this person doing the same thing three
days in a row if he was just arrested
it's like the swifties are finally about
to meet Alvin brag yeah like it's it was
such a funny tweet but it's true like
this is a violent person who like trusts
past three days in a row and every day
he was able to get out and do it again
wait until they hear about the two cops
that were beat up by the illegal
migrants they're going to be big
mad so I think the account should be
taken down I do think this is like an
interesting route for her to take to do
that but I'm sure she thought it was
like the best way I wonder if she's like
even involved she definitely is
she definitely is yeah I think she
should talk to Elon and by the way a lot
of celebrities have these accounts and
at different moments in time like
there's a lot of attention on them like
there was those weeks where everyone was
obsessed with the account that tracks
Kylie because she was taking like 30
minute plane rides to Palm Springs and
that's so wasteful so they come in and
out of trend yeah but still for the
stalkers they remain on
alert yeah you know they're still
checking it yeah yeah yeah they stay
woke you know they stay dressed and
alert yeah no it's
definitely there should be some sort
of line yeah I don't know what it is but
it's not it's not right right now and
it's like yeah legally whatever she
might not have a case but like what
about human decency what about like what
about Taylor's reaching reaching out and
saying I feel very unsafe by something
you're doing would you mind not doing it
and the person just being like okay like
what about hello yeah well what if you
just called Taylor up and said I feel
safe right are you ready for our next
story which isn't so much of a story as
it should be a story yeah what number is
this number four yeah yeah yeah Carrie
Underwood has low key become a
homesteading tradwife on her Instagram
and nobody's talking about it um we are
we shall be talking about it it's so
funny Carrie Underwood has obviously got
the homesteading bug because she is
making her own soap now making her food
from scratch she's been sharing making
her own skincare oh yeah skincare she's
been sharing it a bit to her Instagram
not enough and I don't think people are
asking enough questions about what's
Carrie up to but let me tell you it's
the least shocking thing ever like she
would like she definitely lives on some
sort of farm she has like tons of land
she probably has animals she has a lot
of money like it's easy to Homestead you
know by choice like it's fun you know I
love this journey for her her content
about it is so funny like knows it's
funny too yeah it's just so crazy how
we're all I wonder what like big Tech
has invested in us becoming homesteaders
it kind of seems counterintuitive but
like I am only invested in this because
I'm getting served it I would have never
known if I wasn't getting these videos
in my algorithm you think big Tech has a
vested interest in women becoming
homesteaders like no I actually think
the opposite so why is this happening
right and it's really it's viral I feel
like it's kind of a glitch in the m
Matrix
yeah or it's like too powerful a trend
it's too powerful to stop us from
surfacing right anyways I love this
journey for her it also like then made
me check out her Instagram which was a
really fun place to be she's got a lot
going on like of course the music the
career the glitz the Glam Denim and
Diamonds we know but she also was like a
really really popular atleisure line
amazing what's called like Kalia or
something it's a really popular no and
people myself included just like forget
about her sometimes but she's not to be
forgotten like her hits they don't stop
they don't stop coming and she's doing
like a Las Vegas residency I would love
to see I need to take myself to Vegas
for a weekend just to hit up the
residencies but I would actually need a
whole week because I want to see Carrie
Underwood I want to see Kelly I want to
see Christina Aguilera MH who else is
there I need to I want to see Adele of
course Adele Donnie and
Marie Donnie and Marie
Mar I don't think I can name one song
that Donnie and Marie Osman sing also
are they brother and sister or husband
and wife husband and wife I'm saying
that's my that's my guess Curry Donnie
and
Marie they are um brother and sister
they had a TV
show brother and sister that's cute that
is cute we love when you Google Donnie
and Marie the first thing that comes up
is Donnie and Marie sleep together oh my
my gosh I don't know these songs morning
Side of the Mountain no this is like so
beyond
my no Miranda Lambert will be
doing oh yeah she's doing a residency a
residency I could see her
yeah okay that's pretty much it I didn't
miss anything I don't think cool you
know it's a it's a great time for music
in Vegas maybe we should go oh I don't
know this
weekend oh that would be something
Sunday
night but the tickets are wild for Vegas
oh and the and the private jets you
can't get a parking
spot oh like at The Hanger yeah have you
seen that it's all like it's going to be
hard to get your plane in there damn
good thing I don't have a plane good
thing that would be really hard no
like that's like such a rich people
problem like I never even thought about
that like
their planes the plane uh the private
airport is going to be overflowing but I
feel like should all consolidate no you
would think I feel like that happens at
every Super Bowl especially when it's in
a place that doesn't really have a lot
of private plane volume which I feel
like Vegas does right I feel like
actually of all the cities equipped to
handle like inbound celebrities Jets
people tourism Vegas is probably one of
the best to handle it if not the best
yeah I think
so and they have so many hotels cuz
usually like when it's in a city so many
rooms a normal City like you don't have
every Hotel like there's plent of rooms
there's plenty of rooms I'm glad that
they won't have like a room shortage me
too um before we dive into the next
story might might I have the floor oh
Claudia of course you can the rest of
today's fabulous and inspiring episode
is brought to you by skims we normally
find bras to be so uncomfortable and
restricting they're the first thing we
take off when we get home but skim has
totally changed that you know we love
skims underwear and we have their bras
of course and they've delivered again
their bras are worth the hype for the
amazing shape and support they give but
what we weren't expecting was how
comfortable they were even the underwire
bras that they have we are wearing all
day we barely even notice they're
definitely not the first thing we take
off when we come home anymore so skim is
a brand jacking I have loved for years I
think the best part about skims is like
yeah super comfortable they look really
good but Jackie and I are women you know
we are real women if you know what I
mean like we don't have fake boobies we
have big boobies boies we have boobies
that have breastfed we have boobies that
have lost a lot of weight those are
boobies that need real support they need
bras that feel like real bras and
whatever type of bra you're looking for
whether it's a bralette or like a full
coverage support a minimizer bra every
bra I have in different whatever like
variety I have from skims the bralettes
are my absolute favorite to wear at home
they're creating the next generation of
underwear and bras for everybody so
again they're super super size inclusive
they go from sizes uh 30A to 46h so
that's 62 sizes they're made with
Innovative technology to give you the
best shape and support every bra is
designed with the comfiest and softest
material so you'll feel like you're
wearing nothing at all believe the hype
they have over 100,000 F star reviews
for a reason skims bras are available at
skims.com plus you'll get free shipping
on orders over $75 if you haven't yet be
sure to let them know that we sent you
after you place your order select
podcast in the survey and select our
show from the drop- down menu that
follows and if you're looking for a gift
free Valentine or for yourself skims
just launch their best Valentine shop
ever also available at skims.com today's
episode is also brought to you by bowl
and branch in a recent customer survey
96% said that Bowen brand sheets get
softer with every wash their sheets are
made with the rarest 100% organic cotton
their signature weave feels buttery and
breathable to start and unlocks new
levels of softness with every wash you
can feel the difference with their 30
night WorryFree guarantee I just got
brand new bow and brand sheets for like
5 years I had the Signature hemed
Collection in white and it was good I
loved her but my new aesthetic my
apartment's very kind of natural I don't
know if I've told you like The Vibes are
very organic wood I've got a you know
hints of olive it's giving very kind of
woodsy very Cullen if you will and I
decided to switch up my bow and brand
sheets I ordered the signature sheets in
what was the color natural so it's kind
of like offwhite it's not white like
paper white it's more like beige if you
will it has Jackie it has I will changed
my entire home like you don't even know
like I highly encourage I know you're
you're you love your way but just no I
know you told us that and it definitely
I actually just ordered new Euro Shams
from and Branch but my bedding is white
so I had to get them in white but I was
feeling a little natural curious right
right they have a ton of different
colors they go for every bed from you
know twin to California King you can
sleep better at night with the softest
sheets from Boland Branch get 15% off
your first order when you use promo code
toast at band branch.com that's bowl and
Branch b o l l a n d branch.com promo
code toast exclusions apply seite for
details bowl and branch is just like a
tried and true sponsor of the toast We
Stand we do and I just got new things
from them it was so exciting so did I
are you ready for our fifth and final
story a little oh and just to say I had
ordered something and like ordered the
wrong color like a
[__] gray I got gray and it just
doesn't go with my new aesthetic the
customer service was amazing they put
like a stop tracker like it and I didn't
even call us chy you know I called us
just just customer number 365 mhm I
actually I was shopping I saw a bowl and
Branch store do you know they have
physical stores I didn't and I was
wondering could you walk up and check
out with code
toast we'll have to ask them yeah that
should be like a fun perk mhm our last
story a little Royal update Prince Harry
has left the UK 24 hours after seeing
his dad King Charles and not seeing his
brother Prince William Prince Harry is
already leaving London he'll be on the
last train to
London after that's quick after a quick
trip to see his father King Charles
shortly after bucking him announced that
the Monarch was diagnosed with cancer he
was spotted at London's Heathrow Airport
on Wednesday after spending about 24
hours in the
UK I just feel like I don't know
anything I just feel like that wasn't
the plan you think he was like turned
away at the door no or it was a bad
conversation I'm leaving Papa yeah I
mean that's like a it's a by the way
from LA to London that's like not a
short Journey for 24 hours to say hi and
bye I I think he probably didn't book a
return flight at first just wanted to
feel out the Vibes this is just my
speculation based on you know human
behavior and I think the Vibes were
negative and he turned around and went
home that's what I
think interesting I mean it's a really
short amount of time for such a long
flight so I don't know what the hell
happened I doubt he was going there with
the intention of seeing William that
part doesn't shock me but I would
imagine he would have spent more time
with his father right and so if it was
that sort of thing of like you know time
heals all this is bigger than us then
Charles would have been like stay see
your brother let's be a family yeah
24-hour trip is just not given that no
it's giving bad news Spar it's giving
drama
continues yeah for sure for sure like
The Saga like with the picture we sort
of painted yesterday that like hopefully
this would be the thing that brings them
all back together him and Megan are
working Royals again like seems further
away than ever it's also giving like
things just got worse oh like what was
said yeah like we it it they sunk Down
Deeper yeah I mean there was like that
recent drama with the translation of
their book well not their book like the
biography that they um Obi scobby right
and the translation accidentally putting
the name of the person who made the
comment about Archie's skin tone so I
feel like tensions are probably higher
than ever yeah
yeah so yikes yikes bikes but you know
bom
Voyage yeah safe travels do you think
Megan and Harry will be at the Super
Bowl no and that's the problem because
like what if that's where they should be
that's where you should be like former
Royals living high on the hog go to the
damn Super Bowl right but that's like so
such an American sport you know and
she's American she is she is but it it
just would be crazy like they'd be
better off at like you know the World
Cup or whatever of course but she in New
Jersey if you're not using your clout to
go to the Super Bowl in Las Vegas then
you're just not doing it
right I mean I couldn't agree more like
if I was Megan and Harry like I would
have had a suite A Jet and a like a
hotel room months ago no I would be
getting on someone else's I don't even
care who's paying I'm going I'm sure I'm
sure anyone would give them a ride
Oprah
Jeff Bezos Ellen does Ellen have a plane
for
sure yeah and it's it's like a quick
trip it's not big ass it's so true it's
literally nothing and everybody's going
to have extra seats like they're just
they should be there today's episode is
not over because we have our TV recap
which is our Vanner pump rules recap
which was on last night the second
episode of the season first episode you
know wasn't great second episode was
better because like at least someone
somewhat polarizing Tom sandal I know
you're like obsessed with seeing the
Sandy it's the everything else I'm sorry
is so beyond uninteresting to me like
the restaurants like it's just
not remotely interesting and seeing
somebody so unhinged like that's
entertaining to me yeah I guess he
wasn't really even like that crazy or
bad like the episode was not good no no
no it wasn't good but when I look back
on the episode and like look at my you
know heart rate monitor and think about
the things that excited me and made me
feel something I would say seeing the
way that Ariana and Tom live within the
one house with the
assistant was appalling obvious we spoke
about the the St state of their which is
not acceptable but the way that they
communicate through that poor woman who
is so ill equipped like she's not a
alpha type of Personality she's
obviously like soft spoken maybe even a
little
shy how did she end up in this situation
how did she get here how do she get out
like she's not the right woman for the
job no and I feel badly for her you know
she probably was applying for a personal
assistant job and she became like a
divorce mediator um you know but she
stays in the job so I did relate to like
her sending off that text message really
quickly and then Tom changing his mind
like that's so me I'm so quick that's so
you that's so not me yeah like that
would that would happen to me like you
said you told me to do something so I
did it sorry I appreciated that she did
that because Tom it's like your words
like you said something you can't undo
it yeah and actually I didn't really
agree with um Lala sort of taking Tom's
side you did agree no oh I I agreed with
Lala I felt like she was being ration
rational I think like him saying I'll
send you at a hotel is like Beyond
unreasonable and insane and I get Ariana
being like indignant in this birthday
party but the more I learn about like
their financial situation when it comes
to the house like Ariana is being a
little too too prideful like I
understand what she's saying she's like
you ruined my life like I shouldn't be
uprooted and have to find a new place to
live but if he is willing to buy her out
and her only reason for saying no is
because like on principle she's really
only doing herself a disservice like
look how she's living like a slob like
like a slob she can't even stay at at
her residence with her new man she's
shooting herself in the foot like to
prove she making so much money she could
get a better house to prove this point
to someone who a point is he's going to
miss it and as Lala said like he's
getting off on making you uncomfortable
like she thinks that leaving is like
going to be too easy for him and that
she's sticking it him by being there
like he doesn't care either way and why
wouldn't you want a clean s why would
you do this to yourself the way the
state of limbo that she's living in like
I I don't relate to it at all and I and
I she's lost me on this I I don't
understand it don't understand how Tom
Ken buy her out when he was saying he
literally had to move like $500 $1,000
just to pay his band and that's the only
reason he was going on the the tour even
though it felt you know like such an
inopportune time he needed the money
which I do believe but like and he did
put he put more than Tom Schwarz into
Schwarz and Sandy so that over $500,000
like I do believe he has no money so how
can he even buy her out I don't know not
my problem not my problem but like maybe
he like I don't think that's even like
an actual realistic option he might
still have savings even if he put close
to a million in the restaurant he's been
on the show for a very long time I if he
and he doesn't seem like he spends
outlandishly aside from his band that's
like his passion project he could have
more savings okay yeah yeah um so I
think that's like a like a mistake on
Ariana's part like she's just so um like
being stubborn about it and she's wrong
she she's only doing herself a
disservice yeah because you can't move
on if you're still like if you're still
caring about like punishing the other
person right and living I mean it's just
it's un it's obscene I cannot believe
that that's how they were living and I
think how they're still living I also um
oddly found and I've been finding like
one of my favorite characters to be
Sheena mhm she's so she went from being
just like so fake and
like insufferable to being so real and
honestly like I just love her Brock and
I just love her like she's really a
sweetie she's really a sweetie I agree
like I I stand I do too and I really
like her and Brock and they have a a
very nice family life and I like
watching the family stuff from everyone
yeah I could live without you know the
birth charts and the Zodiac readings
from Ally well yeah that's not even I
don't even know what that is so dumb um
sad to see pump go you know a local
institution but I thought Lisa's
reasoning for it was like very
reasonable yeah and like I I wouldn't
consider Lisa's you know restaurant
discography to be a flop she's like
opening a million more restaurants in
Vegas like those are the real money
makers she doesn't need four restaurants
on the same street in West Hollywood
yeah and I I'm with her like it's you
have to know when it's time to say
goodbye to something like yeah all good
things must come to an end rather to end
it with dignity right right and like the
fact that people like showed up for it
like it was cute and the rents going up
like it's dollars and cents it's dollars
and cents like this is a business not a
charity yeah and it's also like you
don't keep your business going just to
like preserve your reputation if it's
like losing you money right right and
it's really not an integral part of like
the Vander pump universe not at all I
couldn't believe all those tried in the
beginning I couldn't believe all those
scenes that were filmed there I'm like
oh why were they filmed there because
when it was opening like it was a big
part of the storyline and then like Tom
worked the bar and they were
like on Vander pump rules they tried to
make it a part of like the show's
ecosystem but it wasn't natural and it
didn't work and and I think the
restaurant probably suffered because of
that because it wasn't like a place you
would go to see Vanderpump people you
would go to Sir right and then they that
was changing right and TomTom is what
pump would have been but there wasn't
enough of Balian makes sense to me yeah
so it was time yeah it was time um but
like other than that I don't have any
thoughts on the recap like it
wasn't interesting no I found it not
pleasant to watch I'll keep up with it
because I'm sure there's going to be
meet at some point but I it was just
like start stop start stop
yeah um so that's our show correct which
is like disappointing cuz we finally got
like back into something and we're both
watching watching it and it's like n
yeah no like we will continue to do de
to do deer toasters on Thursdays like
until the show becomes you know
untenable yeah but I'm going to give it
a beat they're finding their new footing
it's hard you you have to bring Sanda
ball back into the full but like what he
did was so horrible and people are so
mad I had forgotten about China's other
song and that music video that was
insane oh my God that music oh my God
Claudia I I was shocked I literally had
forgotten about that it's it's a sex
tape yeah literally it's
skinx it's insane and what was crazier
about at the time was like that guy
Brett was hooking up with was it Dana
Dana who sheena's friend so it's like oh
I'm going to tap this guy you're hooking
up to me in my music video and it's this
like the thing is Sheena is a complex
gal and we have just you know witnessed
her growth and that this honestly I feel
like this episode that really honest
conversation she had about like OCD with
her motherhood and like with the
flashback to like the girl she used to
be like I just feel like it's emblematic
for lack of a better word of the journey
she's been on like it really highlights
like how much she's changed honestly she
should be very proud yeah and the theme
of this episode is growth change is
positive but it it was shocking to look
back on that I had completely forgot
that that was something that happened
and it was such a low production value
like it really was giving pornhub.com it
was a porno yeah with your friend's man
which was
what
Beyond so that is our show you guys hope
you have a great hump day don't forget
to hump someone you love and thank you
so much for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the fast life stories that you need to
know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also AV
aable as to podcast anywhere podcast can
be found so Spotify iTunes Stitcher
public radio I Radio cast box all the
places why you listen to podcast my not
toast leave about a beautiful standing
and goodly talented we are hope you guys
have an amazing day and we'll see you
tomorrow love you
bye